hey youtubers is charlie I've new
legends of tomorrow footage so I'm gonna
play that when we talk a little bit
about Vandal Savage and what's going on
with the flash arrow finales so here we
go we all know history is written with
pens with bullets war is God's Way of
moving the human race forward I'm here
because the future of the world is in
peril because of a man named Vandal
Savage I chose you eight to travel
throughout I to stop you got the wrong
guy euro in on IRA's where I'm from you
aren't just considered heroes your
letters now it's up to you shall we
you're just a lost assassin used to care
of good-for-nothing criminals I can live
with her we have the power to change our
own fate
they're here
dc's legends of tomorrow series premiere
thursday january 21st on the CW i'll go
ahead and say spoiler warning in case
you guys haven't seen the flash arrow
crossover episodes from this week the
flash episode 8 in arrow episode 8 we
find out that Vandal Savage is reduced
to ashes using an enthil with it Merlyn
at the end of the episode picks up the
ashes and says you owe me one buddy so
yeah you shake your fist at merlin but
what i really want to know is this what
is the favor that merlin is going to
call in with Vandal Savage like what if
the original ratio goal comes back and
Merlin needs his help please Vandal
Savage save me from corrections to the
Canon the joke there's that Merlin was
never head of the League of Assassins in
the comics but I totally love with John
Barrowman it's done with the character
on TV way better than his comic book
counterpart the question we're left with
though is how does Vandal Savage come
back and we're not going to find out
till episode 1 of legends of tomorrow
they did say like that they would
totally explain it in that episode which
we now know is on january twenty first
but because his life force is tied to
Hawkman and Hawkgirl as we learned
during the big flash arrow crossover and
it has something to do with enth metal
i'm just i'm wondering if Merlin is
going to uncover a you know here too for
unknown Lazarus Pit and combine it with
some special magic to make him whole
again my guess is those that when they
do bring him back he will still be tied
to Hawkman and Hawk girl's life force so
he'll still have to kill them to
maintain his immortality if you remember
in the comics he was just blanket
immortal like he didn't need to do
anything special to stay immortal so
they changed that on the TV show just to
make a little more meaningful between
the characters just create some more
conflict I won't really argue with the
logic it just makes for better TV it
just gives him more of a reason to want
to kill Hawkman and Hawkgirl if he's
going to be the hat set character from
their origin story now I totally love
the actor that's playing Vandal Savage I
think he's going to be really awesome in
the role the only complaint I have
against this story and this is really
just a function of them not having a lot
of time in that to our crossover episode
is explaining why just because he gets
jilted by Hawkgirl that he wants to kill
her again and again across space and
time but I think they meant to imply is
that before he became infatuated with
hot girl and she spurned his advances he
was already a really evil priest of
Horus so kind of seemed like he was
looking forward to the nth metal sky
rocks as they called them destroying the
Egyptian Empire the only problem when
they brush over a back story like that
on TV like the
last season one is a good example like
at the end of the season when Barry is
like why do you hate me so much
reverse-flash and he's like it doesn't
matter like he completely brushes over
it but you spent all season with those
characters so you've gotten to know them
quite a bit like you kind of know what's
going on inside eobard thawne's head
when he says that when we meet Vandal
Savage in this episode we really have no
idea what's going on in his head only
that he thinks that the kingdom is in
danger from the sky rocks and he wants
to have sex with hot girl so it seems
like the premise for legends of tomorrow
is that Vandal Savage has a much more
grand plan for the world because before
that like we don't get any of that in
the big crossover episode like he just
tries to seek out Hawkman and Hawkgirl
to kill them so that he can live forever
why does he want to live forever because
he's supposed to live forever so it's
kind of it's kind of a week reason so I
think legends of tomorrow will give him
an actual reason for wanting to take
over the world there's a whole bunch of
other stuff happening in this trailer
besides Vandal Savage Hawkman and
Hawkgirl like the other big thing that
I'm most excited about is learning more
about the firestorm character and you
know like what what they're going to do
with it based on what happened in the
comics now the comics is littered with
firestorm stories so they might be
picking bits and pieces will just have
to watch for Easter eggs but I think in
terms of like really big crazy stuff
like I'm not expecting them to get into
god particle territory that's like a new
52 storyline I'm expecting them to just
have fun with the idea of transmutation
that's like a power that we haven't seen
firestorm use on the show yet now all
these characters you have seen them use
their powers on the flash and arrow and
various episodes but they did say that
by the time they get to legends of
tomorrow episode 1 a lot of the kinks
will be worked out there'll be much more
badass than they're portrayed on the
screen like the atom is the best example
like a lot of his gear will malfunction
from time to time they said that most of
that's going to be worked out by episode
1 legends of tomorrow in the other bill
promise of the series is a ship based
show like right now Star Wars hasn't
come out so space opera isn't a big
thing it's not really in vogue right now
it's been a long time since Battlestar
went off the air but after episode 7
just start expecting a whole lot more
sci-fi space opera so if you're big fan
of those types of stories you're gonna
have a lot of fun legends of tomorrow
will be that DC ship-based show I
wouldn't really call it space opera
because the Waverider rip hunter ship is
going to stay local to earth but it is
interesting to think about them doing
more space based stories in season 2
season 3 you know how
seasons the show ends up going I know
there's a rumor that's been going around
that they like they spent way too much
money on season one and the CW is
worried it won't be able to fund a
season two don't believe any of that
till you hear from the producers usually
they don't greenlight shows for second
seasons till after the first season is
completed its run in this supposed to be
almost like 16 episodes of legends of
tomorrow so it's gonna be a while before
we hear about that speaking of space I
know a lot of you guys have been asking
me about the Batman V Superman trailer
are those parademons during the
nightmare Batman sequence I think that
that's a hallucination but I do think
that they are honoring the pair demons
of the comics they're just meant to
invoke that for people that have read
the comics people that haven't read the
comments will probably just think
they're really scary so I'll say yes to
parademons but I will say no to Darkseid
that is like way way off in the distance
if the movies ever decide to go to Jack
Kirby's fourth world stories giveaway
time though congratulations to this
week's reverse-flash giveaway winner
creeper rebellion please private message
me on the back end of my channel so i
can get your contact info what's going
to happen is is I have a new flash video
that I'll post some time this weekend
I'll go ahead and start a new round of
the giveaway whenever I post that whole
bunch of Wally West stuff happening I
just come I'm going to push all my Wally
West news to that video I've got a whole
bunch of other stuff that I'm working on
this weekend there's the doctor who
finale up some more game of thrones
telltale they just announced a Batman
telltale Game I'm so excited about that
it's going to be so much fun while you
guys wait for everything you can click
here for my Batman V Superman trailer if
you haven't seen it yet or like a
billion times and you can click here for
my arrow flash crossover episodes thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight